für den inhalt dieses spots sind alle
parteien verantwortlich
[Musik]
wir wollen nicht wieder etwas zu wählen
sollen nichtwähler für ganz blöden
daraus staumauern infrastruktur verkehr
so der falter mit ihm redest du mit ihr
also alles wie immer die staus in einer
wegen einer länger siebten monat die
märkte rot grün in nrw gesagt und das
ist auch so falls diese familie zum
einkaufen losgefahren ins da war der
junge neben hier drei jahre alt hat in
deutschland prinzip handwerker kommt
zwischen 8 und 18 uhr unabhängige
autobahn die krippe zwischen 2017 und
2020 ist losgefahren sagt die
schwarz-gelbe nrw-regierung dir bis 2010
130 stellen gestrichen und planungs-
bau- verursacht also ich sag mal so ich
habe noch nie auf autobahnen bauarbeiter
arbeiten sehen
kleiner witz für alle parteien eine
fertig gestellte strafe in deutschland
fair news.de alle marode hier die
straßen die brücken überall stören
schlaglöcher wollen wir mal wer der
vater es tat gut das ist kein rotwein
trinke glück noch nie wieder raus die
flecken
[Musik]
manchmal weiß heutzutage nicht in der
disco mit nebelmaschine oder eine
innenstadt von stuttgart erwiesen ihm
eine großstädterin vom fahrverbot hat
ist eine radikale baujahr 2005 webseite
dreckschleuder aber der einzige grüne
ministerpräsident der kretschmann der
sagt ja der saubere diesel kommen er
hatte sie mitte bahn muss halt genug
zeit mitbringen
also noch mal zum vergleich das hier ist
ein alfa dreckiger diese sauberer neuer
eur 96 diese viel besser
[Musik]
verkehrsinfrastruktur das verwalten will
hier lange gegen ein für die bürger da
draußen wählen dafür brauchst du
internet du kannst du mit mir
unterhalten
die über wählen
für den inhalt dieses spots sind alle
parteien verantwortlich